[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 برنامج
مهمه السوداني التعيينا تعيينات ومكتبه
تثير الشكوك وتنذروا بعقوبات والمناصب
الامنيه تثير خلافا في الكواليس مع
المالكي
ثلاثيه الثلج والرمل والوحل من تحالف
روسيا اوكرانيا
بلا مرشح معركه وهميه في الانتخابات
النصفيه
الاكثر وانفاقا الاوقافا
المانيا لم تعد دروس التاريخ من روسيا الى
الصين لكن برلين مسؤولين لا مستشار تقاوم
[موسيقى]
بعد اسبوع من تواليه المنصب تعيينات
السوداني الجديده ومستمره خمسه تغييرات
داخل مكتبه الشخصي جاءت بعد تغيرات اخرى
في مناصب امنيه عليا تجنب الاطار
التنسيقيه الذي جاء به للحكومه اعلان
موقفه بشكل واضح منه
شهر عسل سياسيه بالطبع يعيشه معظم
المسؤولين الجدد مع الشعب والسوداني ليس
استثناءا عكست قراراته الاخيره محاوله
دغدغه مشاعر الشعب تغييره بالمناصب العليا
وعوده لمكافحه الفساد لكن بما انه مدعوم
من قبل الاطار التنسيقي الموالي لايران هل
هي في رئيس الحكومه المكلف بوعوده فعلا عن
هذه التغييرات في المناصب الامنيه تندر
بالخلافات
اي وزير
يصدر اوامر ويبدا تغييرات وتعديلات في
وزاره
مريض نبين وكانه واحنا جايين ينتقم او جاي
نحذف ونلغي الناس اللي موجوده كل اللي
موجودين هم موظفين في الدوله العراقيه
حسابات ام
نك
لكن هل سيشك طريقه بعيد عن الاطار المولي
لايران الذي اجلسه على كرسي
الواقع يشير اه عفوا
لي عكس ذلك التصفيه حاضره للسابقين عكس
حديث السوداني وتماما كما حرض المسؤول
الامني مش حزب الله العراقي والملقب بابو
علي العسكري لنا حقوق يجب تحصيلها للشيعه
العراقيه بدات في لعبه خطره والبدايه مع
الرجل الاول على لائحه تصفيه الحسابات
الكاظمي
[موسيقى]
لكن هناك صله اعماق توصل السوداني
ميليشيات وتتسع دائرتها مع الوقت مكتبوا
الاتصالات لرئيس الوزراء العراقي الجديد
التعيينات وبدات لكن بمن معد واشنطن
لسياسات الشرق الادنى الادنى سلط الضوء
على الامر ربيع نادر مديرا للمكتب
الاعلامي لرئيس الوزراء صحفيو معروفا
بالعملي طويلا مع جماعاتي جماعات المصنفه
على لا هات الارهاب والموظفون في هذه
القنوات العالميه التي عمل بها نادر سابقا
لتدقيق امنيا شخصيه على يد الحارس الثوري
الايراني والاختيار يتم بناء على التقارب
الايدولوجي يبدو هذا جليا في منشورا
السابق لنادر على مواقع التواصل اعيد نشره
عقب توليه منصبه يخلد ذكرى جنازه ابو مهدي
المهندس الذي قتل مع قاسم سليمان بغاره
امل امريكيه في يناير من العام 2020
ولافتت هو ان ربيع نادر نفسه انضم لي قسم
الاتصالات خلال رئاسه عادل عبد المهدي لكن
متى جاء تهمه عندما تولى الكاظم المسؤوليه
رغم اتصالات السوداني المستمره مع واشنطن
متولي المنصب اخرها بوزير الخارج
بالاصلاحات التي وعد بها العراقيين لكن
يبدو ان مكتب السوداني مهددا بالعقبات
استمرت هذه التعيينات بحسب تقرير معهد
واشنطن السؤال اين المعارضه من كل هذه
القرارات والتعيينات ونتحدث عن الصدر
الغائب عن المشهد منذ تولي السوداني
والظاهره اخيرا وبلا سياسه تعيينات مكتب
السوداني قد تكون لصالح شخص اخر رئيس
الوزراء الاسبق نور المالكي وائتلافه الذي
يحاول باسرار التسلل لمكتب السوداني
والهدف تلميعته الملكه هو الاخر يسعى
لتصفيه الحسابات مع الحكومه السابقه
وتقرير لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط يؤكد ذلك
طريقه الاداره امر اخر مختلف عليه بين
الثنائي المقربون من السوداني يكشفون ان
التقاطع بينهما لم يبقى خلف الابواب
المغلقه طويله اذا نحن امام خلافا قد يلا
يظهر للعلن قريبا ويبدو ان الكواليس ستكون
مسرح الاحداث لان اخرين يراقبون الخلاف
وهم قاده الاطار التنسيقي انتظروني نهائيا
ومن اجل انت هذه الفرصه دخوله جيل جديد
قال لي رياده البيت الشيعيين مثل قيس
الخزع قائد ميليشيا العصائب تم عناوين
قديمه جديده لا تكاد التغيب عن الساحه
السياسيه
الملفات همم الملفات
وهي ملفات ترثها الحكومات المتعاقبه
ويراقبها الجميع فما الذي
سيفعله محمد شياع السوداني بهذه الملفات
المفخخه السوداني لديه فرصه كبيره
اقتصاديا لوضع البلاد على سكه الاصلاح
سلفه مصطفى الكاظمي ترك احتياطات ماليه
الضخمه وهي تقدر بنحو 85 مليار دولار في
الخزينه ومئه وثلاثين طولنا من الذهب لم
يسبق لرئيس حكومه عراقيه عن حضيه بمثل هذه
الميزات خاصه منذ عام 2014 وحتى تشكيل
حكومه الكاظم
ودعم اخر
السودانيه محبوبه بدعم برلمانيا وسياسيا
طويله لكن السودان المدعوم مقيد لماذا
لارتهانه لجهه سياسيه متورطه ايضا بالفساد
وهذا يفتح الباب امام تساؤلات عديده حول
نهج السوداني وان كان يجرا على طرق باب
الفساد حتى الرجل اطلق تصريحا من هيئه
النزاهه لا خطوط حمراء امام اي ملف فساد
تحركنا في وجه الفساد اذن لكن هناك تحركا
اخر
قرا على انه انتقام السياسي من الكاظم
وربما يتبعه لاحقا انتقام من الصدر
والسوداني الغى قرارات قرارات اللي سلفاه
هو افعى عشرات المسؤولين ومصطفى
حساسه في الدوله رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات
القاضي رائد روحي ورئيس جهاز الامن الوطني
حميد الصفري
خطوه تثير القلق حول ما اذا كان الاطار
التنسيقي يصفي حساباته لكن الاطار ينفي
والسوداني يؤكد انها اعاده هيكله اللافت
ان اللواء الركن حامد السهيري قائد الفرقه
الخاصه لحمايه المنطقه الخضراء قيل لعدم
تصده لانصار التيار الصدري العز الحين
اقتحمه المنطقه الخضراء الصغير الصيف
الماضي والمفارقات الحث الشعبي اقتحم
بدباباتهم ومدرعاته المنطقه الخضراء فيما
يلعب الماضي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا هالكشر السوداني عن انيابه في ايامه
الاولى للرئاسه الحكومه ان ما يجري ليس
الا تنفيذنا لخطابه الاصلاحيه والوطني
المؤشرات الاوليه تشير الى غير ذلك بل
تذهب الى ما هو اخطر تنفيذ اجنه الاطار
التنسيق الموالي لايران بينما هناك من
يراقب ذلك بسنت مغلق من التيار الصدري
الصامت الغائب او الغائب الغاضب صحيح انه
انسحب من العمليات السياسيه لكنه لا زال
يملك الادوات لتغيير اي معادله السياسيه
وهنا نتحدث عن الشارع الحاضر دوما
يتاهب لاي خطا وربما ينفجر في اي لحظه لكن
هل سيشعل السوداني هذا الفتيل ربما فاصابع
الاطار والملك حاضره الحكومه الجديده امام
محمد تلامسه حدود خطر في تحركاتها وليس في
فساد ولا في الشارع فحسب بل تمتد حتى
الشمال حيث اقليم كردستان والملفات
العالقه قضيه كركوك الاكراد يطالبون بضمها
والمناطق المتنازع عليها بين الحكومه
المركزيه وحكومه الاقليم وايضا ملف انتاج
وتصدير النفط لدى رئيس الوزراء يسير في
حقل ملغم داخليا وخارجيا ايضا يتوجب عليه
خلقه ذاك التوازن الضائع بين ارتهانات
السياسيه وولايات الخارجيه تؤشر بوصلتها
بوضوح نحو الشرقي نحو ايران وهذا ما يثير
التساؤلات حول علاقات بغداد اقليميه
ودوليا واشنطن التي ترى في الحكومه
الجديده شريكا يرى البعض انها لا ترشرش مع
واشنطن ملحه فالجهات التي شكلتها اعدائها
واضح لامريكا اوضح
تحدثنا عن حدودي خطر قد يلامسها السودان
ومنها الفساد وهنا الطريق معقده هل هو جاد
في محاربته والى اي مدى يمكنه الاستمرار
والى اي حد او بالاحرف ما هي الهوامش
المسموح بها
يواجهه السوداني بلدا من اكثر البلدان
فسدا في العالم احتل العام الماضي المرتبه
المئه والسبعه والخمسين
عن 180 دوله بحسب منظمه الشفافيه الدوليه
في كل مفاصل الدوله ممثله الامين العام
للامم المتحده في العراق
تقولوا ان الفساد الجزء من الحياه اليوميه
خسر العراق بسببه
450 مليار دولار من وزناته العامه بين
عامه
و2015 اي اكثر من نصف موازنته العامه التي
بلغت
850 مليار دولار خلال تلك الفتره وهذا
الكلام لرئيس الوزراء الاسبق عادل عبد
المهدي طيب ماذا لو قلنا ان نحو 50,000
موظف وجندي في وزاره الدفاع ليس لهم وجود
ويتقاضون الرواتب هذا فعلا ما كان يجري
بحسب رئيس الحكومه الاسبق ايضا حيدر
العبادي في سبتمبر 2014
150 مليار دولار موهبه من عوائد النفط منذ
عام 2003 تقديرات اخرى تقول ان المبالغ قد
تصل الى 600 مليار دولار في فتره زمنيه
اقل هي ما بين 2006 و28
هنا مثلا في حقل الزبير النفطي دارت
عمليات تهريب تورط في تورط فيها ضباط
بيرتب عاليه وموظفون كبار والعمليه كانت
تتم عبر احداثي ثقوب بخطوط التصدير النفط
الكميه المهربه فذرت بكم بحدود خمسه الى
سبعه صهريج وبسعه 50,000 لتر يوميا وبما
يصل الى خمسه وسبعينه مليون لتر الشهريه
لمتابعه مشاهدينا هذا الملف ينضم الينا من
اربيل عبرزوما الباحث السياسي هو عثمان
اهلا بك اذا
بدانا معك من حيث انتهيت من النفط تحديدا
فاولى عمليات التهريب كانت في ايام
المالكي ومن عصائب اهل الحق والميليشيات
المواليه والتابعه لايران الا يجب ان يبدا
السوداني من هنا بمحاربه الفساد بدلا من
اقاله الزهيري مثلا والذي يعني معروف عنه
بانه حامل العصا ذهبيه من جامعه سانت هيرس
وايضا المعروف بانضباته العالي
بالتاكيد طبعا تحيه الك و ااا لمشاهدين
العربيه الكرام ااا يعني ما نراه من خطوات
من السيده السوداني
اعتقد علينا ان نتانى بعض الشيء لانها
نحكم منذ البدايه على مدى فاعليه هذه
الخطوات كل رئيس وزاره ياتي في خلال حتى
الشهر الاول
من عمله يقطع الكثير من الوعود يقوم
بالكثير من الزيارات الميدانيه
يحاول ان يحل بعض الملفات ولكنه سرعان ما
يصطدم
بجدار الكتل السياسيه
المتحالف معه غير المتحالفه معه ايضا
ويتقن بعيده فتره قصيره لانه غير قادر على
ان يحدث لو ينجز مع واحده بانجازه كمحاربه
الفساد او حصر السلاح بيد الدوله وكل هذه
الشعارات الاخرى التي حاول الكثير من
رؤساء الوزاره
واذا استمر او اذا همم يعني كان هناك
اتجاه عكس الاتجاه الذي يعني من المفترض
ان يكون فان حكومه السودانيه ستتعرض
لعقبات
الامريكي امريكا حقيقه اصبحت مع كل تطور
جديد في العراق امريكا تصبح اقل واقل
اهميه عن الفتره التي تسبقها يعني راينا
كيف تتردد السفيره الامريكيه وكانها في
حفل كبير وكان همم يعني همم نزل عليهم
الانقاذ الكبير بتشكيل هذه الحكومه ويبدا
وهم فرحين جدا بهذه الحكومه همم اغلب ان
هناك شيء من الاتفاق لا اعرف اذا كان
مباشر غير مباشر بين الولايات المتحده بين
ايران همم العراق ربما قد يكون له الحكومه
لنا واا اتفاق الاستراتيجي لكم وبقاءكم في
العراق لكم يبدو انه هذا هو الاتفاق لانه
الطريق التي يرحب بها الامريكان همم السيد
همم الحكومه الجديده
ومتغلين التماما عن حقيقه انها حكومه
ايطاليه مدعومه من قبل ايران ولو الاطار
التنسيقيه المدعوم من قبل ايران همم
فيه بعض المؤشرات على ربما اتفاق ضمني
امريكي ايراني حول تسليم العراق الى
الجانب الايراني والامريكان وهذه الاداره
الجديده الغيره بها حقيقه بما يجري في
الداخل عراقي يتحدثون باننا باقون ولا
نذهب وكل هذا يعني قبل ايام السفيره
الامريكيه في اربيل في منتدى الشرق الاوسط
في ميري منتدى مركز البحوث للشرق الاوسط
قالت باننا باقون تحدثت بثقه بانهم باقون
بنفس الثقه التي يدعمون بها حكومه السيد
السوداني يعني الكثير منها همم
يستنتج واستمره وجود شيء من الاتفاق همم
ربما غير المعلن بين الايرانيين وبين
الامريكان حول العراق وربما حول دول
الاخرى في المنطقه
الحكومه السوداني وهناك حديث عن العقوبات
كما قلنا اذا كنت معنا من اربيل عبرزوم
الباحث السياسي هو عثمان شكرا لك
الاوربيونا يظنون ان شتاء 2022 صعب جدا
هناك ما هو اصعب في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
ليس مشهدا في شارع لشخص عاديا يرتاد
دراجته الهوائيه بل هذا رئيس تشيلي
غابريكا الاصغر في تاريخ الدوله اللاتينيه
بالمناسبات
الى
القصر الرئاسي وهذه هي وسيلته الدراسه
تفاعلا كبير على منصات التواصل مع الفيديو
الدراجات يبدو انها سينما في قصر تشيل
الرئاسه
الفكره في سبتمبر ومن طفل
تشيليين حتى يصوتوا على الدستور الجديد
الذي انفذه النهايه طفل يرتدي زي سوبر مان
عبد الله يدور حول الرئيس لما
حديثه عن الدستور اكمل لكن ربما عندما
انها خطابه فكر في فعل ما فعله الطفل الا
بالدوران وانما بالذهاب لمقر عمله للقصر
الرئاسي وبنت دراجه
عقيده ان روسيه لا تتبدلوا بتغيير حكام
الكامل روسيا يمكنها فقط الاعتماد على
جيشها وعلى
عمله حليف القديم
نابليون الى الحرب العالميه الثانيه اراضي
روسيا البارده لا طالما دافعت عنها اربع
وحروب كبرى لعب فيها الجنرال الابيض دورا
حاسما على الجلي يبدا انكسرت احلامه الزحف
المغول باتجاه اوروبا وفي الشتاء وبسبب
البرد ان هزم السويديون في حرب الشمال
الكبرى وخسروا بذلك سيادتهم على بحر
البلطيق وما بين الوحي والجليد تبددات
جيوش حمله
النازيه التي شنبها الراي الثالث ضد
الصوفيات وفقدت المانيا
حينها بالحرب الخاطفه
الزمن والصقيع سندس
المانيا
قبل تحقيقها النصر النهائي لكنه موسكو هذه
المره تواجه خصما يلعب بالورقه نفسها
اوكرانيا وتاريخيا لدى روسيا مشكله ان لعب
خصمها بنفس الطريقه الحمله الصوفيتيه على
فنلندا شتاء عام
1939 روسيا تكبدت 10 اضعاف خسائر حسون
البشريه قبل سيطره عليها والشتاء نفسه
وقتها وقفه ضد ستالين الذي جلس جنونه من
اجل التدفئه واكل السجق اللي يخسروا معركه
عرفت بنفسه اسم الوجبه اذا هو نعمه ونقمه
الشتاء يفرض استراتيجيته على الجيوش
السباق انطلق منذ اسابيع روسيا تريد تجميد
الحرب والحفاظ على ما كسبته من اراد حتى
الربيع اما كياب فتلعب كل اوراقها من اجل
تعويض ما خسرته قبل فوات الاوان
ما بدايه الشتاء القارس في روسيا الذي
يحمل معه درجات حراره منخفضه تصل احيانا
الى دون 30 درجه مئويه يبدا فصل جديد من
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وجوله جديده من الصعوبات امام القوات
الروسيه خاصه مع وجود نفس في تجهيز جنود
الروس الذين تمت زياده اعدادهم مؤخرا
صعوبات عند قد تواجهها القوات الروسيه في
ارض المعركه بحسب تقارير بدء من صعوبات في
تشغيل المعدات العسكريه ومرورا بالحاجه
للمزيد من الوقود لتشغيل المعدات
وامكانيتي اخفاء الالغام تحت الجليد
وانتهاء بامكانيه تحرك الامدادات في الليل
فقط لان الغطاء الميداني سيصبح اقل امور
كلها ستدفع القوات الروسيه لتغيير
الاستراتيجيه
دفاع وليس الهجوم
الحرب هو هذا الشتاء لن تكون كما كانت
روسيا رغم خسارتها لاراضي اقليم خاركيز
الا انها تمكنت حتى الان من صد الهجوم
الاوكرانيه على دونجا وخرسون حرب الشتاء
مختلفه والسؤال مع من سيتحالف الشتاء هذه
المره روسيا بدات الخطه مبكرا استهدفت
منشات البقاء الضروريه في اوكرانيا المدن
الاوكرانيه الكبرى بدون ماء وبقاء سكان
بدون تدفئه بحلول الشتاء مستحيل
ولقتنا روسيه اخرى اللاجئون سيتنافقون على
اوروبا بالملايين وموسكو بذلك سوف تضرب
عصفورين بحجر واحد اغرقوا اوروبا
بالمهاجرين وافراغ المدن الاوكرانيه من
سكانها من ماذا يسهل اقتحامها لاحقا
اما بالنسبه لارض الميدان اكتساؤل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بالحله البيضاء سيجعل المعدات
العسكريه مكشوفه الثلوج تستخدم في هذه
الحالات لزرع الالغم واخفائها وهذا عدا عن
الاسلحه التي تفقد الكثير من فعاليتها
نتيجه البرد موسم الوحلات سيكون اخطر من
اشهر الجليد ربما وطول الامطار الغزيره
سيعيق الرؤيه انظمه الملاحه وحتى صور
الاقمار الصناعيه ستفقد الكثيره ستفقد
الكثيره من ثقتها اللون الابيض لان يفرش
البساط الاحمر لاين من الطرفين في البقاء
على الاراضي الاخرانيه سيكون مرهقا
للروس خمس مئه مليون دولار على الاقل
يوميا بحسب اليوزميك خاصه انك تحضر تحضر
لحرب الاستنزاف تعتمد على المدفعيه بعيده
المدى
ايامه صعبه تعيشها هذه الايام اوكرانيا في
ظل انقطاعات الطاقه الكهربائيه حيث تاثرت
اربع محطات رئيسيه باستهدافات روسيه واخرى
توقفت بشكل ملحوظ يتوقع ان يتضرر من موسم
شتاء هذا العام داخل اوكرانيا اكثر من 4
ملايين ونصف مليون شخص اذا استمرت
انقطاعات الطاقه ومحطات التدفئه
واتابع من مع ضيفي من استديو القاهره
اللواء اركان حارب الدكتور محمد الشهاوي
مستشار كليه القاده والاركان ورئيس اركان
الحرب الكيميائيه سابقا اهلا بك اذا
بمعطيات الارض اليوم بالنسبه للطرفين مع
من سيتحالف الشتاء مع روسيا ام اوكرانيا
الابيض ده سيمسم طريق الحزم من اعلم ان
الشتاء والثلوج والبرد واستهداف محطات
الطاقه ديه ستجعل اخرى الاوكرانيين يتم
خفض روحهم المعنويه سيتم ايضا التدفئه
ستكون صعبه جدا علشان كده صحيفه تلجرام
البريطانيه بتقول ان الاوكرانيين سياده
المجمدون من البرد في حاله عدم امدادهم
بوسائل التدفئه
ومحولات ومولدات الكهرباء بل وان ايضا
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بلانكن اثناء
اجتماعه في مجموعه السبعه قال ان روسيا
بتسعى لجعل الاوكرانيين يتجمدون من البرد
هذا الشتاء وعلشان كده بنقول يعني
الثلج ده او الشتاء او الجنرال
ابيض كما يطلق عليه
تقديرات للاستخبارات الامريكيه لو سمحت
لنا تقديرات للاستخبارات الامريكيه تقول
ان الشتاء سيعيق الحركه الروسيه كما نتابع
ويحتها تتحدث تحديدا عن الفتره الموحله عن
موسم الوحل
ده مهم جدا لان فعلا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والغرب وفي اطار الحرب النفسيه
هم يقولون ذلك احنا نعلم ان الارض هو
الطقس بتعمل لصالح المدافع وعلشان كده كان
الرئيس بوتن انتهت استراتيجيه هذه
الاستراتيجيه
بتعتمد على اربع محاور المحور الاول هو
استخدام يعني حرب الطاقه
الاستراتيجيه من خلال يعلم ان الغرب
سيعاني خلال هذا الشتاء وخفض الروح
المعنويه الاوكرانيا المحور الثاني هو
زياده المزيد من القوات وتعزيز الخطوط
الدفاعيه لانه بيدافع بينما سيكون هذا
الشتاء ضد القوات الاوكرانيه لانهم يقومون
بالهجمات المضاده وده بيحتاج حركه والحركه
ستكون الارض موحله وبالتالي بناء ان هناك
تحديات اعتقد ربما وهنا ربما يجب ان يتوقف
عند هذا لو سمحت لنا
ال التعليق من استاذ بجامعه دارتموث
الامريكيه يقول ان الراس بوتيتسا او موسم
الواحه لا سيكون من بين الفرسان الاربعه
للجيش الاوكراني وهنا كان يتحدث عن جافلن
وستنجر تيك توك ايضا اي ما يعني به
الاعلام وايضا موسم الوحل
اعتقد ان برده زي ما ذكرت سابقا ده احنا
نعلم ان الغرب وامريكا بتنتدب استراتيجيه
تسمى استراتيجيه الاستدراك او الانفلينج
وايضا الاكاذيب الاستراتيجيه التي تصب في
صالح او بدوافع وطنيه هم يقولون ذلك الى
قبض الروح المعنويه لروسيا لكن الواقع
بيقول غير كده التاريخ بيقول غير كده اربع
مرات ضد المغول ضد السويدين وضد الفرنسيين
واخيرا ضد الالمان في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وبالتالي بنقول فعلا ان همم
اوكرانيا اكثر لانها لا تقوم بالهجوم اما
روسيا في تقوم بتعزيز خطوبتها الدفاعيه
متواجده ولدها في استراتيجيات العلوم
العسكريه بيقولوا ان الارض
بتلعب لصالح المدافع وليس المهاجم ايضا
باعتقد ان هذا الشتاء ايضا هو صحيح لا
يساعد على الاخفاء والتمويل لان الثلوج
البيضاء وعدم تواجد الغطاء الخضر او
الاشجار وبالتالي صعوبه والتمويه الالغام
كما ذكر التقرير بتكون بتختفي تحت الثلوج
ويصب شفا اما الاكثر خطوره هو ان درجه
حراره جسم الانسان
والمعدات بتكون اكثر في الشتاء مما يجعلها
عرضه للصواريخ الباحثه عن الحراره
وبالتالي صعوبه الطيبات
وايضا الى الروس اشكرك اشكرك من استديو
القاهره اللواء اركان احد بعد دكتور محمد
الشهاوي مستشار كليات القاده والاركان
ورئيس اركان الحرب الكيميائيه سابقا
ورقه الشتاء تلعب على اكثر من جبهه ومنها
جبهه التدفئه والغاز الروسيه المنقطعه عن
اوروبا الخوف كل الخوف من الشتاء قادم
الصعب للغايه لكن هل تتخيل ان الشتاء هذا
العام سيكون رحيما بشتاء عام 2023
المعلومه صادمه نعم لكن الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه اكدت ان اوروبا نجحت في تخزينه 90%
من متطلبات الشتاء القادم من الغاز لكن
القادم هو تاكيد الخبراء ان غالبيه الغاز
المخزن مصدر وروسيا وهو لن يكون متوفرا في
الشتاء 2023 وحتى البدائل التي تحاول
اوروبا
اليها من اجل الغاز
المتعاقد عليها بعد ان شهد اقتصادها
تراجعا وهو قد لا يحدث في العام المقبل
والعهده على شركه الايطاليه المدير
التنفيذيه للشركه الايطاليه اتوقع ان
تزداد رق الاحتجاجات الاجتماعيه العام
المقبل بعد ان بات غالبيه الاوروبيين
يدفعون 50% من مداخلها على الطاقه
الاوروبيون اباتو يدفعون في بعض البلدان
اسعارا اغلى ب 15 مرات مما يدفعه
الامريكيون مقابل الغاز والنتيجه غلاء في
كل شيء وبريطانيا
طره للتخلي عن وجبه واحده على الاقل يوميا
خلال الثلاثه اشهر الماضيه فيما لجا
ملايين اخرون الى التقليل من كميات الاكل
المستهلكه او عدم الاكتروس بنوعيتها هذا
يعني ان 40% من المستفيدين من الدعم
الحكومي يفوتنا وجبه واحده على الاقل
يوميا ثمانيه وثلاثون بالمئه قالوا انهم
لم يتمكنوا من شراء ما يكفي من الطعام
فيما لم يستخدم واحد 28% من الناس غاز
الطهي بسبب غلاء اسعار الطاقه بنوك الطعام
من جانبها قالت انها زادت نسبه قروض
الطعام المقدمه للمحتاجين لنسبه 50%
مقارنه بما قبل وبعد كورونا حكومه
بريطانيا
عشرات المليارات من الجنيهات لكن
الاجراءات هذه لم تعد كافيه
اجراءات الحكومه وضعت اربعه 34% من في
ديون لانهم لم يتمكنوا من مواكبه ارتفاع
فواتيرهم الاساسيه
ايضا قليله تفصلنا عن الانتخابات النصفيه
الاكثر الشراسه منذ عقود في الولايات
المتحده بالنسبه للديمقراطيين على الخساره
ليست سيئه في كل الاحوال وتحديدا بالنسبه
للجيل الجديد في الحزب صعود السلم نحو
ادوار القياده الاعلام الامريكيه تحدث ان
الخساره ستعني اعتزال الجيل المخضرم وعلى
راسهم رئيسه مجلس النواب نانسي الاثنين
والثلاثين عاما للعوده الى ارض اجدادها
عبر منصبن اديب رومانسيه
اما الجمهوريون الفوز وقد ان يرشح كافه
شريحه على الاخرى ايضا
واستنقسامه حول عددا من الملفات مثل حجم
الدعم المناسب لاوكرانيا وتزوير نتيجه
الانتخابات الرئاسه الاخيره وتحول من
جمهوريه
كيف ما يقرب من نصف الجمهوريين الذين
يترشحون لمنصب الفيدرالي او على مستوى
الولايه يتفقون مع الرئيس السابق ترامب ان
الرئاسه سرقت منه لكن رغم كل هذا هناك
معركه جانبيه تعتبر الاهم رئاسيه وليست
نصفيه بين الرئيس الحالي
وسلفه دونالد ترامب بالنسبه لترامب تمثل
الوجوه الجمهوريه التي راها عليها مؤشرا
على حجم نفوذه في الحرب النجاحهم سيقطعوا
اي شكوك حول هويه المرشح الرئاسي
الجمهوريه بعد عامين اما بعد ان الذي
انخفضت شعبيته خلال عامين من الدعم
التشريعي لمشاريع قوانينه ستعني السيطره
الجمهوريه على الكونغرس ان يقضي ما تبقى
من ولايته مكمل اليدين مواجهات الشرعيه
اقرب للخساره التحقيقات حول ملفات العده
وعلى راسها
فوق الوثيقه بالفوز باغلبيه قويه في مجلس
النواب في الانتخابات النصفيه بعد ايام
وهناك مؤشرات على زياده مقاعدهم في مجلس
الشيوخ موقع 5308 كان يظهر ان
الديمقراطيين سيحافظون على غالبيات ضئيله
في مجلس الشيوخ لكن الموقع بدا منذ ايام
يرجح احتماليه فوز الجمهوريين باكثر مقاعد
المجلس ووصلت نسبه الاحتمال الى اربعه54%
اما احتمال الفوز الجمهوريين باكثريات
مقاعد مجلس النواب فارتفع الى اربعه و80%
الاسباب عديده وعلى سبيل المثال للحصر حسب
الرئيس يخسر في الانتخابات النصفيه اضافه
الى التضخم وارتفاع نسبه الجرائم
وترامب هيوحو بالعوده ساترشحوا على الارجح
بينما ايضا قلق للغايه على الديمقراطيه
ومن اجل ذلك الانتخابات النصفيه مهمه ومن
اجل ذلك تصرف على اعلاناتها المليارات نحو
تسعه مليارات و 700 مليون دولار الانفاق
الاجمالي المتوقع في الانتخابات النصفيه
للكونجرس بحسب شركه للابحاث رقمهن قياسي
يفوقوا السباق في الانتخابات 2018 بمئه
واربعه واربعين في المئه وابقى الاقامه بس
التكلفه الاجماليه للانتخابات الولايات
والانتخابات الفدراليه يتوقع ان تصل الى
16 مليار و700 مليون دولار وتغطيه حاجز ال
14 مليار دولار التي انفقت في انتخابات
الرئاسه الامريكيه الاخيره
احتدامه الحرب الحزبيه والاستقطاب
السياسيه الداله لرفع قيمه الرهانات
الانتخابيه لمجموعات المصالح والشركات
سعيا بضمان مصالحها استقطاب تعاكسه
الارقام 80% من الديموقراطيين والجمهوريين
يعتقدون ان الحزب المنافس يشكل تهديدا
سيدمر اميريكا اذا لم يتم ايقافه اليوم
ولهذا فهي الانتخابات الاهم في حياه
الامريكيين برامج مثل اكتب له
الديمقراطيين ووين براد للجمهوريين سهله
المساهمات الصغيره هذا العام تبرع الاشخاص
بمبلغ 200$ او اقل ليصل الاجمالي الى نحو
مليار و100 مليون دولار هيضعف ما كان عليه
الحال عاما 2018 التي هذا العام ايضا كان
ارتفاع تبرعات القادمه من خارج الولايه ما
يقرب من ثلثي التبرعات اللي مرشحين مجلس
الشيوخ جاء من مساهمنا خارج الولايه بدلا
من الناخبين المحتملين لكن هل لهذه
الاموال تاثير فعليه على الفائز الاحصاءات
تجيب بنعم خلال ال 20 عاما الماضيه عاده
ما يفوز المرشح الذي ينفق اكثر اتجاه اقوى
في مجلس النواب منه للشيوخ لكنه ايضا
موجود في الاثنين سباق مجلس شيوخ الاكثر
اعتدادا وبالتالي الاكثر جد للمبالغ
القياسيه يتوقع ان تتجاوز نفقات اربع
معالق انتخابيه فيها اللزونه جورج
حاجز المئتين مليون دولار لكل منها
المفارقه تكمل في ان المعركه الاغلى في
الانتخابات خاليه من اي مرشح بل هي
استفتاء على مشروع الصراع يشرع المراهانات
الرياضيه عبر الانترنت في ولايه
كاليفورنيا اكثر من 400 مليون دولار من
الدعايه لكل من مين الفكره ومعارضينها
مجلس النواب محسوم
للجمهوريين بحسب استطلاعات الراي اما
الصراع الحقيقي فهو في مجلس الشيوخ
وتحديدا في الولايات الخمس التاليه اذا ده
جورجونا في نيفادا توجد اربع مناطق
انتخابيه للجمهوريين افضليه الفوز في
المنطقه الثانيه اما المنطقه الانتخابيه
الرابعه فستذهب للديمقراطيين الذين
يمتلكون ايضا افضليه طفيفه للفوز
بالمنطقه الاولى ومع بقاء المنطقه الثالثه
غير محسومه لاين من الطرفين جورجيا
تتضمنوا 14 دائره انتخابيه ضمن الجمهوريين
تسعه مناطق منها مع بها اربع مناطق
للديمقراطيين بينما لم تحسم المنطقه لم
تحسن المنطقه رقم اثنين حتى اللحظه وفي
مناطق انتخابيه في شعبه الج واخرى مرشحه
للانضمام اليهم بينما يظهر اللون
الديمقراطيه الازرق في منطقتين هما
الرابعه والثانيه
يمتلك الحزب الجمهوريه الافضليه كاسحه في
سبع مناطق انتخابيه وافضليه طفيفه في
منطقتين اما الديمقراطيه فهو مرشح للفوز
باربع مناطق انتخابيه ومفضل للفوز في
منطقتين اضافيتين مع الطبقي الصراع مفتوحا
على كل من المنطقه الثامنه السابعه عشره
مناطق انتخابيه اريزونا مناطق انتخابيه
التاسعه اللون الاحمر الجمهوري على ست
مناطق منها ثلاثه شبه محسومه وثلاث مناطق
اخرى تميل للجمهوريين بينما اكتفت
الديمقراطيون
حسنين منطقتين فقط ما عم خلافهما الافضليه
في المنطقه الثالثه
[موسيقى]
النوم في مقر العمل من اجل العمل لا يكفي
ماسك القضاء مواجهه قادمه في الساعه بعد
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا ماسك ينفذوا تهديداته تسريحه
الموظفين رسميا وباي نسبه النصر تمام
اخر عندما تخسر الشركه اكثر من 4 ملايين
دولار وهكذا غرد ماسك المسؤول واما السؤال
فهل تنتهي هذه الاجراءات القوانين
الفيدراليه الامر يتطلب فتره اختار مدتها
60 يوما وهذا ما يستند عليهم
السوى الدعوى القضائيه التي بداوا في
رفعها على ماسك والملفات ان قبل ساعات من
هذه القرارات كانت مديره اداره المنتجات
في تويتر تستلقي على ارضيه مكتبها بمقر
المنصه
في سبات ويبدو عميقا وليس قيلنا والهدف
هنا محاوله
ما يطلبه منها كثير قبل انتهاء المهله
التي وضعها للتسليم
الجنون هو فعل نفس الشيء مرتين بنفس
الاسلوب ونفس الخطوات وانتظار نتائج
مختلفه هذا ما يعتقده البرت اينشتاين
بنفسه لكن هل يمكن ان تنسحب هذه الحاله
على المانيا
نحن في الاول من فبراير من العام
1970 اجتمع في مدينه السن مسؤولون المان
مع نظرهم في الاتحاد السوفيتي والهدف كان
توقيع اول عقده لخطي النقل الغاز من
سيبيريا الى حدود المانيا وقتها ورغم
القلق الغربي توم اند برلين حلفاءها لن
ندمن الغازات الروسي لكن العكس حدث
وبالعوده الى حديث اينشتاين هل تفعلوا
المانيا هذا الجنون مره اخرى الصين قد
تكون الخطا التالي صناعه وليس طاقه
بكين
منذ جائع
[موسيقى]
سكوتر من كم سنه
السؤال هنا هل يمكن ان تخطئ المانيا مجددا
في اعتمادها على الصين في الصناعه كما
فعلت مع روسيا في الغاز
المتخصصه في الابحاث في الصين افي ما يخص
القطاع الخاص تعملوا خمسه الاف شركه
المانيه في الصين الاقتصاد الالمانيه اصبح
اكثر اعتمادا على الصين في النصف الاول من
عام 2008
المعهد الاقتصاديه الالماني اشار الى ان
الصناعه الالمانيه استثمرت حوالي 10
منهارات اليورو في الصين في النصف الاول
من هذا العام وحده رقم القياسيه
قاعده تظن ان الارقام اتوضح اعتماد الصين
على صناعه المانيا لكن خبراء المان لديهم
وجهه نظر مختلفه يمكن اللي بدك اياه مع
النصر نسخوا ما نصدره اليها
وبسهوله وهذه براعه الصينيه تقليديه لكن
مره اخرى هل ستفعل المانيا في الصين عما
لم تفعله مع روسيا
لونجيكا اكشن بيبي
المانيا اخذت معارك عديده مع رؤساء
امريكيين عده جيني كارتر و رونالدو بسببي
اعتمادها على طاقه الروسيه والان بسبب
الصين تجدون نفسها في معركه جديده لكن انا
شغل زاره بكين لكن توقيت الزياره اقلق
واشنطن والحلفاء وبعدها اسابيع من فتره
ولايه ثالثه تاريخيه لتشيجن وحتى عندنا
شغل رفضا ان يرافقه فيها الرئيس الفرنسي
حسب رويترز
الحكومه الالمانيه تؤكد ان واشنطن هي اكثر
الحلفاء الغربيين انتقادا لها بسبب
الزياره لكن المصالح
وبتعبيره الخاص
الانتقاد هو الالماني الضنيه الى الغربيه
يبدو ان له خلفيه بسبب ازمه الطاقه وزير
الاقتصاد اتهم واشنطن قبل فتره بمطالبه
برلين باسعالا خياليه للغاز لتعويضي وقفي
الشحنات الروسيه لكن ربما يرغب الطرفان
بوضعه نهايه لهذا الاختلاف وهنا زياره
اخرى لن كان في برلين نعم اجتماع مجموعه
السبعه لكن الكواليس قد تكون محل العقده
تجربته واعاني 70 اي يخشى ان تتكرر في
هامبرغر المانيا تكرر نفس اخطاء الطاقه
الروسيه مع الصين والدليل اكملوا بناءا
بحريا في المانيا والاهم في اوروبا شركه
اكوسكو الصينيه سمح لها بالاستثمار في
المرفق والقرار اثار معارضه غير مسبوقه
داخل الاحتلاف الحاكم الحزب هو
الديمقراطيه الحره
خارجيه هي الاخرى كانت كلها تخوفات هذا
الاستثمار يوسعوا التاثير الاستراتيجيه
والتحكم الصيني في البنيه التحتيه للنقل
في المانيا اوروبا
الصينيه تمتلك اصلا حصصا اخرى في اكبر من
عيني في اوروبا في اوروبا
في بلجيكا وبجانب ميناء في الثناء ما يجعل
السؤال الابرز هنا ماذا لو غازات الصين
تايوان وفرد الغ وعقبه على بكين الاجابه
عند المعهد الاقتصاديه الالماني
هل تستبدل المانيا اعتمادها على روسيا
بالصين سؤال متى يؤرق السياسيين الالمان
هنا ويشكل ماده خلافاتنا رئيسيه بين
الاحزاب الحاكمه طفت الى السطح مؤخرا بعد
اعلان المستشار اولاس عن دعمه لمشروع
استحواذ شركه الصينيه لجزء من مرفقه همبرج
رغم اعتراضي الشريكين في الائتلاف الحاكم
زياره شمس الى الصين رافقتها انتقاداتهم
من قبل الحزبين المشاركين في الاتلاف
الحكومي الليبراليين والخضر وزير
الاقتصادك الذي ينتمي لحزب الخضر حذر من
تكرار اخطاء الماضي في ما دعت وزيره
الخارجيه انا لنا بيربك التي تنتمي ايضا
لحزب الخضر الى استراتيجيه جديده مع الصين
دخول غرفه العمليات في المستشفيات امرنا
صعب على الكبار فما بالكم بالاطفال لكن
هناك دائما محاوله لتخفيف الالم معنويا
على اقصى تقدير والابطال الخارقون
افتراديا حاضرون في الواقع اطباء من الان
1/9 المقبله انا حنين السوري
[موسيقى]
انا بامل انه يعني لو قدرت ان انا احول
من الاطفال
بيقدم لهم طول الوقت اللي هم محتاجينه
مجموعه من القواعد الاخلاقيه والسلوكيه
اللي بتشكل عادات وتقاليد وثقافه اي مجتمع
مجموعه من الحاجات زي الصبر الصدق
والتسامح قررت ان انا اعيش واتعيش في هذا
الكوكب والبلدي واكتشف الاختلافات كثير
وسلبيات كتير فقررت اصلح سلبيات دي بس في
الجيل الجديد اللي هم الاطفال دلوقتي
وحاول اساعد اهلهم في ان هم يكونوا بصحه
كويسه وقوه سوبر اتش
[موسيقى]